to say good evening everyone.
All right. And what we would like to do
is um we would like to have a nice
opening hymn
and we want to do hymn
number.
This is a nice favorite which
haven't heard for a while and that is uh
hymn number 272.
Give me the Bible. Hymn number 272.
All right.
Hymn number 272.
[Music]
Give me the Bible star of gladness
gleaming
to cheer the wonder alone and tempt his
toss.
No storm can hide that peaceful radius
gleaming
since Jesus came to seek and save the
lost.
Give me the Bible
holy message shining.
Thy light shall guide me in the narrow
way.
precepts and promise,
law and love combining,
till I shall banish
in eternal day.
Give me the Bible when my heart is
broken.
and sin and grief have filled my soul
with fear.
Give me the preious
light of Jesus spoken.
Hold up lamb to show my savior near.
Give me the Bible
holy message shining.
Thy light shall guide me in the narrow
way.
Precepts and proise,
law and law combining,
till I shall vanish
in eternal day.
Give me the Bible,
all my steps in lightning.
Teach me the danger
of these realms below.
That lamp of safety,
all the gloom, how brightening
that light alone, the path of peace can
show.
Give me the Bible.
Holy me shining.
Thy light shall guide me in a narrow
way.
Precepts and promise
loyal or combining
till I shall panuish
in eternal day.
Amen and amen.
So, um, in fact, um,
the box, the box. Yes. Thank you. So,
now what we're going to do is, uh, we
are now going to, uh, transition. Thank
you, Sharon, for playing that wonderful
music for us. And truly, the Bible is
our light that will guide us.
And, uh, we are now going to have our
question and answer segment.
And there were many questions that did
come in to this box. And what I want to
do is I want to invite Pastor Randy Ski
up.
And uh let me see if there's a extra
mic.
Please, please. Yes. Yes.
Our
Father, which art in heaven, hallowed be
thy name.
Thy kingdom come,
thy will be done in earth as it is in
heaven.
Give us this day our daily bread,
and forgive us our debts as we forgive
our debtors,
and lead us not into temptation, but
deliver us from evil. For thine is the
kingdom, and the power, and the glory
forever.
Amen. Amen. God is good all the time and
all the time. God is good. Do you still
love God? Can I see your hand? He's a
very nice person. I've said several
times, I recommend God to you very, very
highly.
Very highly.
Let me on this final day give my
personal testimony again for anyone
who's never heard it. My testimony is
brief. All my blessings have come from
God.
All my problems without exception I have
brought on myself.
God has never finish my words done me
any wrong. Never.
And as I like to add, if ever God needs
a letter of recommendation,
I want to write it for him because I
know what he's done for me. And so I
thank my heavenly father for the mercies
he's shown me all the days of my life.
And as I stand in this sacred desk, I'll
try to represent him the best I can by
delivering thus sayth the Lord. Does
that meet your satisfaction?
All right, let me uh
ask God to put his words in my mouth and
uh think. All right, let's pray.
Father,
thank you for this moment to come to you
to seek light and guidance.
As we listen to your word, may we listen
with our hearts, not just our ears.
Speak to us, Father, simply,
directly, powerfully.
Grant us the humility to accept thus
sayth the Lord. I pray this also for
those online. We're grateful for their
presence there. Father, now dear God,
bathe us all in light, the light of
truth. If I've offended you, forgive me,
dear God, and use me as you see fit. In
Jesus name I pray. Amen. Amen. Before I
get into the Q&A, I just wanted to
talk a little about Jesus.
Go to first Corinthians chapter 1. We
read verse 30.
1 Corinthians chapter 1 verse 30. 30
is one of the most awkwardly worded
verses in the entire Bible in my
estimation.
When you start to read it, you'll
understand why.
1 Corinthians
chapter 1 verse 30.
We all have it.
Let's read together. But of him are ye
in Christ Jesus, who of God is made unto
us wisdom and righteousness and
sanctification and redemption. Now
that's the kind of verse that requires a
microscopic reading so we can properly
identify the principles in the verse.
But of him are ye in Christ Jesus. In
other words, by his arrangement we are
in Christ. So who is him?
God the father. But of him are ye in
Christ Jesus who of God is made unto us.
You know, by God's arrangement, what is
Jesus to us by the father's arrangement?
Wisdom,
righteousness,
sanctification, redemption.
In other words,
if you need wisdom,
finish my words, you need Jesus,
and he's the word.
Revelation 19:13,
"And he was clothed with a vesture
dipped in blood, and his name is called
the word of God." John 14:6, I am the
way, the truth, and the life. Christ is
the word. John 1:1, In the beginning was
the word, and the word was with God, and
the word was God. John 1:14, and the
word became flesh. If you need wisdom,
you need Jesus. And he comes to us
through his word. Then there is
righteousness.
In uh Jeremiah 23:6, he is called the
Lord our righteousness. He is our
righteousness. If you need
righteousness, you need Jesus.
He's our sanctification.
He's our what's the last word?
Redemption.
No step in the plan of salvation is
effective without Jesus Christ.
I told you a few day maybe the first
week Calvary is stamped on every loaf of
bread. And I'm not asking for that
alone. Calvary is stamped on every loaf
of bread, on every water spring. Let me
put it more directly. You cannot take a
breath without Jesus Christ.
Were it not for Calvary, this world
would cease to exist. Creation couldn't
function. It is all because of Jesus
Christ. Go with me to Acts chap 17. We
read from verse 22.
Acts 17 verse 22. I didn't think of a
title, but I'll call it it's all about
Jesus.
Acts, the book of Acts, chapter 17.
It's not really the Acts of the
Apostles. It's more properly the acts of
the Holy Ghost,
but we accept the title acts of the
apostles, but it's really the acts of
the Holy Ghost through the apostles.
It's always God working through agents.
Do you have Acts 17? What verse did I
say? Then Paul stood in the midst of
Mars Hill and said, "Hey man of Athens,
I perceive that in all things ye too.
For as I passed by and beheld your
devotions, I found an altar with this
inscription to the unknown God. Whom
therefore ye ignorantly worship him
declare I unto you. Paul is saying
you're worshiping a God you don't know.
Let me tell you about this God. Verse
24. God that made what? The world and
all things therein. Seeing he's Lord of
what? Heaven and earth. Look at that
verse again. God that made the world and
all things therein.
Seeing he is Lord of heaven and earth.
So he not only made the earth, he made
heavens. Dwelleth not in temples made
with hands. Now read the next verse.
Neither is worship how? with man's hands
as though he needed anything, seeing he
giveth to all life and breath. And
in other words, the creator does not
need you.
You see, Jesus is life itself.
I wonder if I can tell you what I'm
thinking. I don't want to confuse you.
Say,
[Music]
When you say something, God holds you
responsible.
All right, let me ask you this.
This is a good time for you to say,
"Lord, put your words in this man's
mouth." When if something lives,
what is necessary?
Breath. Go on.
Well, breath is air.
H.
Well, okay. What's necessary to keep you
alive? You have breath. Breath is from
the outside. Water is from the outside.
Food. Mhm. You need to eat things to
keep you alive. That's if you are
living.
Does God need to eat to stay alive? No.
You said no. Slowly.
That would make him dependent upon food.
Are you listening to me? Does God need
to drink to stay alive? No. So there is
living and then there is life. God is
life.
We live but God is life.
Did I confuse you?
You and I live. Angels live. Those on
unfallen worlds, they live, but God is
just life.
And so Jesus said to us at the grave of
Lazarus, I am the resurrection and the
life.
Life exceeds living, if I can say that
way. Jesus tells us in John 14:6, I am
the way, the truth, and the life. Now
the Bible frequently calls God the
living God. So we can understand that
But God is just life.
We are living creatures. We depend on
this, that, and the next. Not God. God
needs nothing to stay alive. He is life.
How that functions, I don't know.
And so Jesus Christ is to us wisdom
as uh righteousness,
sanctification,
and redemption.
Without Christ, salvation is impossible.
Go to Ephesians chapter 2. Let's read
verse 14. Our subject, it's all about
Christ or I should say Jesus. His name
is really Jesus. Christ is his office.
The function he came to carry out.
Christ means Messiah or the anointed
one. His name is really Jesus.
Are you with me? Yes, his cousin John
the Baptist. The Baptist was not his
name. That was attached to him because
that's what he did. But truly his name
should be John Bar Zachcharias,
the son of Zachcharias. Are you with me?
So the Baptist was not his name. You
don't need to do that to be saved, but I
thought I'd tell you. So Jesus is his
name. Christ is his office.
But he's so connected to his office. Uh
even the Bible writers call him Christ.
What book did I say? Ephesians. What
chapter 2? What verse 14?
We just discovered in 1 Corinthians 1:30
is our wisdom, righteousness,
sanctification, and redemption. What is
he to us in verse 14 of Ephesians 2? For
he is our peace.
Jesus
does not just have peace. Jesus is
peace.
Are you anxious?
Are you troubled?
Get Jesus.
Amen.
He is peace.
I'm trying to promote Jesus. Amen. He is
peace. Amen. He is health. Amen. Are you
following me? Let us go to John chapter
10.
John 10. We'll read verse 7.
John chapter 10. John is a beautiful
gospel. Please read it carefully.
Written by the the apostle or the
disciple closest to Christ. He was also
the youngest. He's the only one who died
a natural death. All the others died
violent deaths. John died a natural
death at around the age of 100
somewhere in Asia Minor, maybe Ephesus
also. All right. Do we have John 10?
Read verse seven with me. Then said
Jesus to them again, verily, verily, I
say unto you, I am what? The door of the
sheep.
I am the door.
Not I have a door. I am. Now these kinds
of statements exceed our capacity. But
we must try.
This is not new. When Moses said to God
in Exodus 3:13, "Behold, when I come
unto the children of Israel, and shall
say unto them, the God of your fathers
have sent me unto you, and they shall
say to me, what is his name?" What name
did God give Moses? I am that I am. I
am. I just am. I am life. I am
existence.
No one can fully grasp that name. I am.
Tell Moses, tell Pharaoh, I am.
He's alive because of me. I am. And so I
am the door of the sheep. Go to verse 11
of John 10. What does that say?
I am the good shepherd. What does a good
shepherd do?
He gives his life for his sheep
which means Christ is unselfishness
not he has it he is selfless.
Let the Bible help you to understand
that. Go to 1 Corinthians 13. Let's look
at the longest definition in the Bible
of love. Because God is love. 1 John
4:16 1 John 4:8. God is love. If he is
love, what is love? Whatever love is,
God is
not God has, he is.
What book did I say? 1 Corinthians,
what? Chapter 13. Let's read from verse
4.
Some of you may know it very well. Are
you there? Read with me. What does it
say? Charity suffereth long and is kind.
Charity envyth not. Charity vaunteth not
itself. is not puffed up. Keep reading.
Do not behave itself unseemly.
Carefully. Now, what's the next
statement? Sekeethth.
Now, let's pause on that because I said
God is unselfishness.
Charity, which is love. The Greek word
agapee is translated charity. Same word
for love, which is God's love. Charity
does not seek its own.
Then it must be it must be a love that
looks out for Yes.
God's love is other focused.
If it's not other focus is not love.
That's why God has to be more than one.
Let me try your mind again.
The Bible says love seeketh not her own.
love all must have an object on which to
lavish itself. Are you with me? Then
from way back at the beginning, the
concept of God had to be more than one.
Not more than one God, but one God in
three persons. For one to love the
other.
If God had been only one person, that
would have been a self-focused love. And
love flows outward.
It must have been more than one to form
the concept of God. And so the Bible
tells us, "Love seeketh not her own."
Keep reading. Is not
is not Come on, read with me. Is not
easily provoked. Go on. Ah, think no
evil. Love is purity of mind towards
people.
Do we think evil of people? Don't answer
me.
Police gives you a ticket. You wish he
runs into a brick wall as he drives
away.
Someone took her your girlfriend. You
wish he breaks his leg
because he took her away twice. So you
can't take that.
Love
thinkketh no evil.
That's Christ.
He is God. He is love. Keep reading
verse six.
Rejoiceth not in iniquity,
but rejoicth in the truth. Now, if
you're practicing error, what is God
doing?
If he does not rejoice in iniquity and
you're practicing error, error is
iniquity. What is God doing?
Ah, you're not with me. My fault.
Let's read the second statement.
Rejoiceth in the truth. Now, if you're
practicing error, what is God doing?
Wait a minute. Or true. True. But listen
again. If God rejoicth in truth and I am
practicing error, while I'm practicing
error, God is looking at me. What is he
doing?
What's the opposite of rejoicing?
He's crying. He's grieving. He's
mourning.
He's suffering.
Are you with me?
If he does not, if he rejoices in truth,
flip that. He grieavves when he sees
people practicing error.
That's love. Love prefers truth.
Love can't stand error.
Rejoices in the truth. Read verse seven.
Beareth all things. Believeth all
things. Hopeeth all things. Let's look
at the third one. What does the third
one say? Hopeeth all thing. God is
hoping someone who's been listening for
the past two weeks will finally make
that decision. Amen.
God is hoping that member who left the
church will come back. Which mean God
exercising some confidence in us, some
faith. Not saving faith, but hoping
faith. I hope he comes back. If God had
no confidence that people will come to
him, he would not have sent Jesus.
Hopeeth all things.
You've got to hope the church will get
better and become more spiritual and
less secular.
Beareth all things, believeth all
things, hopeeth all things. What's the
last one? Endureth all things. As long
as there is time, God endures anything
we do to him,
to save us.
And the worst you can do to God is sin.
He endures it. And so he sees a child of
his who is right now drunk in the
gutter.
And God bears that because he sees the
possibility of that man coming to him.
Are you with me? God sees a daughter of
his at night selling her body. He
endures that because he sees the chance
she will come to him. So he endures that
beareth all things, believeth all
things, hopeeth all things, endureth all
things. Read verse eight. Charity.
Yes. You and I give up. We tell one
another, "I'm sick and tired of you."
We give up. Charity never fails.
You may lose love for someone. You may
lose love for your job. The love of God
never fails. Amen.
That's Jesus.
So Christ beareth all things, believes
all things, hopes all things, endureth
all things. He thinks no evil. Even when
we're sinning against him, he does not
harbor an evil thought.
Jeremiah 29:11. For I know the thoughts
I think toward you, said the Lord.
Thoughts of peace and not of evil.
Let's go back to John.
Let's go to John 14.
It's 4:30.
There's no set time to end, but please
don't get nervous.
We let you out in time. Do you have John
14?
Father in heaven, continue to speak
through me as I try to make this clear
to your beautiful people. In Jesus name
I pray. Amen. Read verse six for me.
Jesus said unto him, what I am the way,
the truth, and the life. I am the way.
To be in the right way is to be one with
me.
To be in the truth is to connect to me.
To have life is to be connected to me.
Which means when you're connected to
Jesus, you're connected to
life.
The way truth. Come on.
But we we said several of the things.
Come on. Come on. Rack your brain.
Redemption. Mhm. Wisdom. Righteousness.
Sanctification.
peace with a capital P.
When you're connected to Christ, you're
connected to all. And now since he's our
wisdom, when you're connected to Christ,
your academic should improve
because he made animals. So your
zoologology should improve.
He made living people, your biology
should improve. Are you with me? He made
the sun, moon, and stars. Your astronomy
should improve. Why? You go to him who
is the original source and he tells you
use this
and I'll bless your effort.
Mhm. When you have Christ, you have
everything you need. But is Christ in
human form still right now? Yes or no?
Yes. So he cannot be with us personally
as I am with you. What's the arrangement
for him to be with us? The Holy Spirit.
So when you have the Holy Spirit, you
have all the things we listed.
So he brings the gifts, they're called
the gifts of the spirit, but he brought
them at the command of Christ. Are you
with me? When Jesus went up, the
disciples were 10 days in uh the upper
room. Then Christ told the Holy Spirit,
"Go take the gifts to them." So really,
they're the gifts of Christ brought to
us by the Holy Spirit.
When Abraham sent his servant to find a
wife for Isaac, Eleazar took a lot of
Abraham's precious things to give to
Rebecca and her family. They belonged to
Abraham, but Eleazar was in charge. So
he took them and gave them to Rebecca.
Now you may call them the gifts of
Eleazar, but really they were gifts from
Abraham. Now Abraham represents God.
Isaac represents Christ. They're two
begotten sons in the Bible. Abraham,
Isaac, and uh Jesus Christ. Rebecca, who
had never known a man, represents the
church.
Eleazar who brought Rebecca to Isaac
represents the Holy Spirit
and he took the things of Abraham gave
to Rebecca's family. The Holy Spirit
take the things of Jesus and gives to
us.
When the Holy Spirit comes to you, he
brings the things of Jesus. Amen.
And so the Bible says, "But of him are
ye in Christ Jesus, who of God is made
unto us wisdom and righteousness and
sanctification
and redemption.
When you honor Jesus Christ, you honor
the Father." Go to John chapter 5. John
chapter 5,
we read verse 22. Verse 23, sorry.
We have John chapter 5 verse 23.
Our little presentation is called, it's
all about Jesus.
John 5:23, I think I said, read for me
that all men should honor how even as
they honor the what do you understand by
even as
The same way you honor the father, honor
Jesus.
Keep reading. He that honorth not the
son, come on, honorth not the father
which have sent him. You cannot separate
the son from the father.
Go to John 14.
What I'm leading you to is when you have
Jesus, you have the father.
John 14, let's read verse 24.
What does that say?
He that what?
No, no, sorry. John 15 verse 23.
15:23.
Read that for me. Now,
he that hateth me, come on, hateth my
father also.
Now, there are many churches, well, I
don't know if there many, but I has
heard of some churches who accept the
father but not Jesus. They consider the
father to be God. They don't consider
Christ to be divine. Jesus said, "If you
hate me, you hate the father." Go to
John 14.
We read from verse six. Our little
subject is all about Jesus.
You have John 14.
Jesus said unto him, "I am the way, the
truth, and the life. No man cometh unto
the father but by me." Keep reading now.
If he had known me, come on. Ye should
have known my father also. Yes. And from
henceforth ye and have seen how and by
from henceforth ye know who him and have
seen him.
How do you see him? Through Jesus
Christ. When you have Jesus Christ, you
have wisdom, righteousness,
sanctification, redemption, peace, life,
the door, the way, the father, the holy
spirit.
What was our subject last night?
Last night. Last night. Last night.
How can you lose
with all of that? Where does all of that
dwell in you?
Let me close with this verse. Go to John
17.
This is Jesus Christ praying to his
father.
It's called the high priestly prayer.
This is really the Lord's prayer. John
17 is the Lord's prayer.
Yeah. Verse 20. Read with me. Neither
pray I for these alone, but for them
also we shall believe on me through
their word, that they all may be one, as
thou, Father, art in me, and I in thee,
that they also may be one in us, and
that the world may what? Believe that
thou has sent me, and the glory which
thou givest me, I have given them, that
they may be one, even as we are one. Now
listen to 23. I in them and thou in me,
that they may be made perfect in one,
and that the world may know that thou
has sent me and hast loved them as thou
hast loved me.
When you give your life to Christ, the
father loves you as much as he loves
Jesus. This is the sort of thing that
causes a a good migraine.
How can God love me as much as he loves?
But that's what the Bible says.
Go to verse 26 of John 17.
Are you there? Read with me. And I have
declared unto them thy name and will
declare it. Listen carefully now. That
the love wherewith thou hast loved me
may be where? In them. And I in the same
way you love me love them. Because I'll
be in them. And since you're in me and
I'm in them, you're in them. And where
this where Jesus is, where the father
is, there's the spirit. Because
according to Romans 8 vers9, the spirit
of Christ is the spirit of God. Same
person.
What's our subject?
Come on. Come on. What's our subject?
It's all about Jesus. When I do that, I
expect you to be quicker.
You're vegetarians. You ought to be
quick.
Are you with me? Am I too hard on you
sometimes? Okay. Huh? Who? Did somebody
say yes? Did an unbeliever say yes?
Okay.
All right. My brothers and sisters, I
recommend Jesus Christ very highly.
What separates Christ from the father
and the son and the holy spirit? When I
say separate, I use that word very
carefully.
He alone is human
and divine at the same time. The father
is only divine. The holy spirit is only
divine. Jesus is both.
Because of that he takes his human hand
and holds us. Takes his divine hand and
holds the father and connects the two
where?
In him.
Are you with me? He takes your hand with
his human hand. takes the father however
he does it the father hath not flesh and
bones and connects us where in him
that's why Christ can say I am the way
the truth and the life no man rich poor
educated uneducated
northerner southerner you name it cometh
unto the father but by me
you've got to come through Jesus.
And so I offer to you or recommend to
you Jesus Christ, your brother in his
humanity,
your God in his divinity. When he rose
from the grave in John 20:17, he told uh
Mary who wouldn't let him go. She was so
happy to see him. Go and tell my
brethren, tell Peter, I ascend to my
father and your father. To my God and
your God. One of the things I look
forward to seeing for my with my own
eyes is how how will the human Jesus
what will he do when we worshiping the
father
in the new anything human must worship.
Are you with me? Jesus worshiped the
father in his humanity on earth. So I'm
wondering what will he do? The Bible
says all flesh shall come to worship
before me. In his humanity, Jesus is
flesh,
glorified flesh. And so I look forward
to seeing what that would mean when we
all assemble to worship the father.
Because in Revelation, go to Revelation
3. Let me show you something. Revelation
3. Let's read verse 12. This is the
message to the church of Philadelphia.
The sixth of seven messages. Revelation
3, the last verse of that sixth message.
Verse 12.
You have that? All right. Now, read
carefully with me. Are you ready? Read
with me. Him that overcomemeth will I
make a pillar in the temple of God? My
God. That's what he says. Keep reading.
And he shall go no more out. Keep
reading.
I will do what? Write upon him the name
of my God. Keep going.
How many times do you see my God in that
verse? No. Look again.
Four times. Jesus keeps calling the
father my God. This is Christ who has
risen.
He still calls the father. Now John sees
a human being. You see? And he says, "My
God, my God, my God, my God." This is
the risen Jesus because he's still
human.
This is just for you to think, not to go
preach, just to think. There are things
we learn and discover that we do not now
understand. But I want you to
understand, if you don't have Christ,
Jesus, you have nothing.
Well, you do have something. Begins with
an S, then a then a T, then a N. But uh
if you need Jesus Christ who is life,
wisdom, redemption, sanctification,
righteousness, you name it, the way, the
door, the the the the good shepherd,
he's everything to us and our peace.
What we need is peace with God
by the removal of our sins. This is only
through Christ. And so I pray and hope
that you, my dear brothers and sisters,
as Champagne SDA
will make Christ your all in all day by
day in everything you do involve Jesus.
1 Corinthians 10:31, you know it very
well without going. Whether therefore ye
eat or drink or whatsoever
ye do, finish it. do all to the glory of
God.
You plan to go buy a suit on Sunday.
When you stand in front of that rack,
ask yourself, which one should I buy
that will allow me to look like a son of
God?
Mhm.
Or the ladies, you go buy a dress, which
one will allow me to reflect my savior,
not look better than the woman in the
office next to me? Which one will allow
me to reflect my is this a purchase for
his glory? Then in other words, you're
living for him.
One of the questions I love to ask
college students when I speak on campus
is what are you studying? Uh economics.
Why? Oh, I love economics. Well, that's
a good reason. Why are you what are you
studying? Uh agriculture. Why? Oh, I
love plants. Good reason. What are you
studying? I'm studying astronomy. Why?
Oh, I plan to go to the moon with Elon
Musk or whatever it may be.
I never hear the person say because I've
seen how I can use it for the glory of
God. And I'm talking to Christians.
Considering the glory of God does not
occur automatically. You have to train
yourself.
Why am I doing this?
Am I thinking of God for when you think
like that? Listen to me. You escape a
thousand perils and traps, aches and
pains because God will make sure it's
all well with you. Why? Because you're
thinking of him. Remember, love seeketh
not our own. So, as you and I engage in
life's activities, let us not seek our
own. Let's seek his.
Okay.
How many of you will say, "Father,
come into my life through Jesus Christ."
again. Can I see your hand again?
Through Christ. Through Christ. Hands
down. Let's pray. Father.
Thank you for Jesus.
We look forward to seeing Jesus.
That man who's also God. The disciples
saw him 2,000 years ago. We want to see
him. The risen glorified Jesus Christ.
Keep us faithful by his indwelling power
represented by the Holy Spirit. and
hasten that day when he shall come to
take us home with him. Keep us faithful.
I pray in Jesus name. Let God's people
say amen and amen. All right, pastor.
We'll get to the questions now. It's a
quarter to five.
The questions are easy. We should be
done quickly.
Question one.
All right. Good.
So, um, I'm going to go through the
questions that came in through the box,
but there were two questions that were
online and I want to get to them. First,
I want to forget. So, the first
question, and just keep in mind if
there's a name, I'm not going to repeat
the name just out of respect. It says,
'The Bible is clear on divorce and
remarage being adultery when the parties
had no biblical reason for divorce
because both parties wandered from the
marriage. Is the remarage able to be
forgiven? That's the first question.
Read that again. I didn't get it worded.
It says the Bible is clear on divorce
and remarage
being adultery when the parties had no
biblical reason for divorce because both
parties wandered from the marriage. Is
the remarage able to be forgiven?
What remarried?
I'm just reading off of what Okay. Yeah.
That's true. You can't read the person's
mind. Yes. I'll try. Okay. What the
person is saying they were in a
marriage.
got divorced without biblical basis.
Uhhuh.
Thank you, Elder. Oh, can it be
forgiven? Yeah. Thank you, Elder Mark.
But God will forgive anything, but it
may require more than just confession
because there's some divorces God does
not recognize. There are some marriages
he does not recognize. Now, the state
may recognize them, not God.
So when that person says, "Can my
remarage be forgiven?"
Yes, it can be forgiven, but you may
have to go further than that. I'll have
to research the official position of the
church. It doesn't come to my mind now.
But I'll stop only at anything can be
forgiven. But sometimes you must go
beyond confess and make him for instance
sometimes we preach in areas where men
have many wives. It's just a custom.
Here comes the man, he wants to be
baptized. Well, we can't have a man with
four wives. We don't believe that. The
recommendation is stay with the first
one you married.
Cease all physical connection with the
others but contribute to their upkeep.
Are you with don't just abandon them
contribute to the upkeep the children
but you must have marital relations with
only the first one. So the others are
like sisters and friends. You cannot
have four wives and become an Adventist.
So that's as far I can go. Yes, remarage
can be forgiven but based on the
circumstances other steps may have to be
taken. But there's some divorces God
does not recognize. Some marriages he
does not recognize.
Illinois may recognize them, but not
God.
Amen. And this is the second one. Thank
you for that. Should the person who
believes now leave the wrongful marriage
in order to be saved? Now, I'm assuming
this is the same same context. So, the
person who believes now, yes, a believer
and an unbeliever. Yes. Maybe there are
two unbelievers. One comes to Christ.
Mhm. No, you stay in the marriage and
let your faithful life be a witness to
that person. Amen. That's a counsel from
first Peter chapter 3. Likewise, ye
wives, be in subjection unto your own
husbands, that if any obey not the word,
they also may without the word be one by
the conversation of the wife, while they
behold your chase conversation coupled
with fear. Uh Peter says, "Stay with
your husband. He's an unbeliever. You're
a believer now. But let your Christ
centered life be the means whereby he is
one. We have a hand over here.
Yeah.
[Music]
become a believer. Do I need to leave my
second marriage? Uhhuh. Because that is
not okay. Well, I'd ask I'd advise that
person to counsel with the leaders of
the church. I'd advise them seek counsel
at the higher levels of the church
because the church has standards. That
would be my counsel to that person.
All right. Thank you, El.
Now, how do you know that's what the
person means? Well, he has an
interesting background. Yes. Yes. Holy
Spirit. Let's leave it there.
I thought you were a prophet. Okay.
All right. Okay. Go ahead.
Now, this is an interesting one. Uh the
person's This is a a different person.
Go ahead. I'm so fearful the Sunday Bill
is passed and my lost. I still have sin.
I don't know what to do. Anyone
concerned about sin in their life is
still the subject of the Holy Ghost's
entreaties. Are you with me? If you are
concerned about your status with God and
you're worrying, it is the spirit of God
working in you. Now, you respond to that
conviction. A person who's cut off from
God has no interest in spiritual things.
May even go to church all the time, but
you can go to church and have no
interest in spiritual things because the
people who said crucify him all went to
church more often than Jesus. And so, if
you if you're convicted about your life,
God's spirit is still working. You're
not lost.
But respond to the conviction. It won't
last forever.
Amen. Um, here's one.
If God knows all things,
then why did he make Lucifer and knew he
would be Satan? Okay. If I had a dollar
for every time I heard that question,
I could buy a house for each of you. How
many of you have children? Can I see
your house? Okay. Did you know that the
child would fall while trying to walk?
Yes. Did you know the child may contract
a childhood disease? Yes. Why did you
still have the child? Don't tell me. You
wanted something to love.
Love. Mhm. So, you had your child. With
all the risks that come with pregnancy
and childbearing, you still went ahead.
I want this thing to love. Well, God
loves more than we do. So yes, God made
Lucifer. God did not make him Satan. He
made it himself. Now God did everything
possible to reclaim him. He wouldn't
come. But the fact that God sees
something may go arai does not mean he
will stop doing what his love drives him
to do.
He saw Adam and Eve would fall, but he
had a plan. But he still made them so
that they could love him, he could love
them. Mhm.
All right. Amen.
Did God know that Satan told Adam he was
naked? Did God know that? What? Know
that Satan told Adam he was naked? God
knows everything. So the simple answer
is yes.
Um
Okay. Well, whether Satan Adam saw you
was naked, right? Mhm. As a result of
disobedience or Satan was involved by
your temptation. Mhm.
Please explain the order of Melkchisedc
in comparison to the order of the
Levites.
Melkisedc enter is enters the Bible in
uh Genesis. Go to Genesis 14.
Genesis 14.
Do you want me to repeat it again? Oh,
it's okay. Yes. Go ahead. Repeat the
question while we look for Genesis 14.
The question is, please explain the
order of MelkiseDC in comparison to the
order of the Levites. Okay.
Do you have Genesis 14? Now, Abraham
fought a battle to recapture Lot. Lot
had been captured by some armies from
the other side of the Euphrates. Someone
who escaped from that war came and told
Abraham. Abraham assembled his servants
318. They armed themselves and they took
off after the invading army. By God's
grace, Abraham defeated that army,
brought back all the captives, all the
goods, brought back Lot and his goods.
Now verse 18, Abraham has returned. And
MelkiseDC, king of Salem, brought forth
bread and wine, and he was the priest of
the most high God. So MelkiseDC, some
people believe, is Jesus. No, he is not
Jesus. He was the literal king of the
city of Salem. He was a king. He was a
priest. Are you with me? Now the
difference between Mechisedc and the
Levitical priesthood. The Levitical
priesthood you can trace the genealogy.
Are you following me? So Levi, not Levi,
yes Levi, Aaron, sorry. And then Eleazar
and whoever else were priests. You can
trace the genealogy. There was no there
is no recorded genealogy for Mechisedc.
So he is used as a symbol of the
priesthood of Jesus Christ. Christ had
no beginning and no end. But MelkiseDC
was a human being. Now let me add two
other things to help you understand.
Christ has three offices. Prophet,
priest, and king.
His role as king is based on the
kingship of David.
Go to Luke 1. Here's what the angel
Gabriel tells uh Mary
about Jesus.
Let's read verse 32 of Luke 1. I believe
that's the verse. Are you there? Someone
read that for me. What does that say?
He shall be great and shall be called
son of the highest and the Lord
the throne of his father David. Yes. So
the kingship of David is the earthly
symbol of the universal kingship of
Christ to come.
That's king. Now let's go to prophet
because Christ was a prophet. Go to
Deuteronomy 18. Read verse 15.
Deuteronomy 18. Read verse 15. This is
Moses speaking now. Do you have that?
Read for me. What does that say? The
Lord thy God shall raise up unto thee a
prophet
say a prophet in the midst of thee of
thy brethren like unto me. Finish the
verse
him you shall hear. Now that prophet was
Jesus. Moses said the father God will
raise up a prophet just like me. This is
fulfilled in Acts 3 22 onward. In other
words, the prophetic ministry of Jesus
is symbolized by the prophetic ministry
of Moses. Now, the prophetic work of
Christ ended when he left. The kingly
ministry of Christ, which will begin
when we go to heaven with him, that is
based on the kingship of David. The
priestly ministry of Christ is based on
the ministry of Melkisedc.
Because MelkiseDC does not have a
recorded genealogy. You notice I said
recorded but he was a literal person the
king of Salem the high priest of the
most high God and so the difference is
the Levitical priesthood you can trace
the origin the father grandfather
great-grandfather no one can do that for
MelkiseDC because there are no records
Jesus of course being our high priest he
has no beginning and no end that's the
difference so Christ is a high priest
after the order of Melchisedc
not Aaron Amen. Amen. Bless you.
The difference between Jesus, God, the
Holy Spirit confused me. Can you simply
clarify this? The difference between
Jesus, the Father, and the Holy Spirit.
All right.
You know, I didn't pray for wisdom.
Sorry. Let me pray. Father, give me
wisdom as I answer these questions.
Please forgive me for not asking
initially.
Put away that sin and speak to me now. I
pray in Jesus name. Amen. All right.
The Bible teaches there three separate
personalities.
The father, the son, and the holy ghost.
They are the same essence, the same
substance which is divine.
Let me put it to you this way. Go to uh
Psalm 146. Psalm 146.
Psalm 146
read verse three.
Put not your trust in come on or in the
now in whom is no help. All right. The
Bible says don't trust man. There's no
help in man. Question for you. Which
man?
your neighbor. Which man?
The word man there is representing what?
Put not your trust in man. Man that is
born of a woman is full of sorrows.
Which man?
It's not any particular man. It is this
species called man.
Don't put your trust in man. Why? Tell
me some things about man. Man is
man sinful. Come on. Heart is deceitful.
The heart is deceitful.
Imperfect. Does not know the end of the
beginning. Does not own anything because
he created nothing. What else can you
tell about man?
Limited. He is
wicked with a capital W. You can the
list can that's man. Are you with me?
Don't trust that.
Whether it's a man in Sagal or a man in
Champagne, don't trust man.
What's the opposite of that? Now, you
can trust God. Whether Father, Son, Holy
Ghost, because a divine being is all
powerful, sinless, reliable, perfect,
possesses all you see in heaven on
earth. Trust God. Don't trust man.
Are you with me? There's a species of
being called God. Ah, trust that. Not
man.
Now, having said that, what's the
difference between father, son, holy
ghost? There's no difference in essence
and substance. There's a difference in
function.
Let me show you what I mean. Go to John
13.
John 13.
I was hoping for easy questions.
This is not easy. But God is good.
That was a good time to say, "Father,
put your words in that man's mouth
because he's struggling." All right. Do
you have John 13? Let's read verse 16
microscopically. My friends online, I
hope you're still with us. Are you
there?
John 13. What verse? Read with me.
Verily, verily, I say unto you, the
servant is not greater than his Lord,
neither he that is sent greater than he
that sent him. Now, what does that tell
you? Who are the two people we have in
that verse? Come on. There are two
people. The Lord and the servant. All
right. What does the verse say about the
two of them? What's the relationship?
One is higher than the other. Who is
higher?
What does the Lord do to the servant? He
sends him.
Are you reading your Bibles? The Lord
sends him. So the Bible say the one who
sends is greater than the one who is
sent. Now listen to John 17:3. And this
is life eternal that they might know
thee the only true God and Jesus Christ
whom thou hast sent. The father sent the
son. So in respect to function, the
father is higher than the son. Are you
following me? With regard to function.
Now go to John 14.
Read verse 26 for me.
But a comforter which is the whom the
fathers will send in. Who sends the holy
ghost in that verse? The father. So
who's higher?
The father. Because the Holy Ghost is
sent. The Holy Ghost does not send the
father anywhere.
Now go to John 15:26.
Be nice and be nice and loud. But when
the comforters come, whom I will send
unto you from the father. Now in verse
26 of chapter 15, who sends the Holy
Ghost? The father. In verse 26 of
chapter 15, who sends the Holy Ghost?
Jesus. In verse 26 of chapter 14, who
sends the Holy Ghost? The father. What
does that tell you? Both the father and
the son can send the Holy Ghost.
Both are higher in function. Now when
Christ was on earth in his humanity, the
Holy Ghost sent him. So Jesus said, "The
the spirit of God hath is upon me. He
hath anointed me in his humanity. But
the divine Jesus is not sent by the Holy
Ghost.
So we have this is where I usually show
it. Equal in essence equal equally
divine. But in function it's like this.
Are you with me? Equally divine. 100%
God. 100% God. 100% God. in function,
father, son, holy ghost.
When Christ was in the garden of
Gethsemane, he prayed, "Father, if thou
be willing, remove this cup from me."
Nevertheless, it's not what I want, it's
what you want.
Go to Philippians chapter 2. Let's put a
a cap on this. Philippians 2,
read verse 12 for me.
No, no. Verse 11.
And at every tongue should confess that
Jesus Christ is Lord. Finish the verse.
To the glory of God the father.
Ultimately the father has to be
glorified. Mhm. So in function it is
father, son, holy ghost. In essence and
substance same thing.
But we're dealing with the mystery. Are
you with me? No human being can fully
explain the godhead. We catch glimpses
and we have to squint because the light
is so brilliant. But from the little we
can see three co-eternal persons equal
in substance but they function
differently. In other it is the Holy
Ghost. Go to Matthew. Let me show you
the difference. In fact, go to Matthew
12. Never forget this passage by the
way. Matthew 12.
Let's read from verse 31.
We're in a question and answer session
at Champagne SDA Church in Champagne,
Illinois,
where the temperature is 92. When I left
my room,
can probably see it on my face. What
book did I say? Matthew, what chapter
12, let's read verse 31. What does that
say? Wherefore I say unto you, all
manner of sin and blasphemy shall be
forgiven unto men. Keep reading. But the
blasphemy against the Mhm. Go on.
The blasphemy against whom
shall not be forgiven. Now read 32.
And whosoever
speaketh a word against who is the son
of man? Jesus Christ. It shall be Mhm.
finish the verse. Whosoever speaketh
against the Holy Ghost, it shall not be
forgiven neither in this world or in the
world to come. Now Jesus saying, look,
you can offend me.
Forgiveness is possible. You offend the
Holy Ghost
and your goose is cooked.
Are you with me? A difference in
function. It is the Holy Ghost that
convicts us of sin. That's one of his
functions to convict of sin. You keep
resisting his conviction, you're
grieving him.
So Jesus said, which is also another
Bible passage that shows us there are
two different people. Jesus said, "You
can offend me and you'll be forgiven."
Don't offend the Holy Ghost.
All right.
Next question. All right. Before we get
to it, review. What did I say about
Father, Son, Holy Ghost? They are the
same in essence or substance, different
in function. All right.
Amen. Um the next one is uh
please explain clearly as possible who
are the 144,000. Are they chosen by God
and are they the only ones in our time
living will be
the same when Jesus comes
apart from those who are sleeping in
Christ. So in other words, please
explain clearly who the 144,000 and are
they chosen by God and are they the only
ones who will be living in the time when
Jesus will come? No, they won't be the
only ones living. If you read Elise's
writings, she said those who have died
in the third angel's message will be
lifted up early to actually see Christ
come back. But 144,000 refers to a
special group of people who have gone
through the terrible time of trouble and
remained faithful to God. the ones who
are alive when there is, as we say, no
mediator in heaven. Christ has left the
most holy place. There's no mediator.
But they are faithful. They've suffered
and they've not denied their God.
They've been tried in the furnace and
they've come through this pure gold.
That's 144,000. They're not the only
ones who will be saved. Of course not.
There's a large multitude of which no
man could number. Elite tells us those
who died under the third angel's message
will be raised to literally see Jesus
Christ come. So they won't be the only
ones ultimately alive on the earth, but
they are special group. Only they would
have gone through the terrible time of
trouble. Amen. The Bible says there's
coming a time of trouble such as never
been. They were the ones going through
that. And by the way, God is putting
many of his people to sleep because he
realizes they cannot go through that. So
when your brothers pass away, yeah,
we're a little sad, but also think God
has just secured that person. Amen. Mhm.
secure that person. Next question.
Now, by the way, the church has no
position on whether it's literally
144,000 or symbolic. Both sides are in
the church. It's not one of the 28
fundamental doctrines. It isn't. Okay.
The the next one is um
false doctrines.
Please
provide. I think that's what it says.
Um,
and uh, I looked at more than one
dictionary with several spellings and
did not find
uh, some definition as far as they're
trying to understand what are false
doctrines. Let me give an example of a
false doctrine. Go to second John.
Second John.
What are false doctrines? Second John,
here's an example. A false doctrine is
anything that's contrary to truth.
Simple as that. Here's one of the worst
false doctrines that has affected the
church. It goes all the way back to the
time of John the Apostle. Do you have
second John? Let's read verse 7. What
does that say? For many deceivers are
entered into the world who confess not
that what? Jesus Christ is come in the
flesh. This is a deceiver and an
antichrist.
This this is a widespread heresy even in
the church today. There are there was
there was a a heresy in the early
centuries called dosatism.
And there were elements of that in the
days of John because John clearly deals
with it in his gospels. Dosatism says
Jesus only appeared to be human. He
appeared to die. It really didn't
happen. It just appeared to be. John is
saying look there are false prophets who
say Jesus Christ did not really come in
the flesh.
This is a this is a a a deceiver and an
antichrist. This is one of the worst
false doctrines. A false doctrine is
anything contrary to thus sayith the
Lord. Perhaps the worst one of all is
Sabbath is Sunday.
Then you deny the creator of heaven and
earth. That's a false doctrine. I don't
mean to hurt anyone's feelings in this
building or lie. That is the most
widespread false doctrine that Sunday is
the Sabbath.
All right. False doctrine. Anything
contrary to truth to thus said the Lord.
And the earliest inunciated false
doctrine was he shall not surely die. It
has affected the whole world. Because
most Christians believe when you die,
you're not really dead. You go to heaven
or you go to hell. You're floating
around somewhere. You know, if I really
believe soon as I die, I go to heaven.
I'd go to heaven right now.
Why am I staying here? Sick, ugly. Why?
Why am I staying here? I'd go to heaven
right now.
So if you say as soon as you die, you go
to heaven. Go.
What's holding you?
Paying taxes and pulled over by the
police. Go to heaven.
No need for resurrection. No need for
resurrection.
Ah, it's so easy to fool people. It's a
shame. Your only defense is this, not a
PhD in astrophysics. This, but don't
give up your PhD in astrophysics. Okay,
go ahead.
Uh, the next one is u,
this is someone online. I have a
building project going on in Africa and
I live here. The people working on the
project work on Sabbath as they are not
Adventists. Since I am not there with
them, should I allow them to work? No,
no.
In Kenya.
What a person said. Oh, Africa. Okay.
Yeah. No,
no. The Bible says don't work on
Sabbath. Yeah. No, man. No. And it's
your project. It's an Adventist project.
Set an example. Don't work. They may ask
you why not. Then you can tell them
about the Sabbath. No. Amen. Um the next
one. Next question. By the way, if
you're rich enough to have a living
made, as is very often common in some
parts of the world, they should not work
on Sabbath either. You with me? In a lot
of countries outside of Western society,
families have living maids. Housemaid,
someone to do the grass, cook the food,
clean the house. Don't they should not
work on Sabbath
because you're an Adventist family. You
should see them as an evangelistic
field.
They should leave your house after
several years having learned about
Jesus, not violating the Sabbath law to
provide breakfast for you.
Yeah. Next question. The next one is
in your previous sermon you said, "Don't
marry a man who is spiritually weak."
What does spiritually weak mean? Unable
to lead spiritually.
The man is the priest. Are you with me?
He's the priest. The reason why God made
Adam first was one reason was he's the
head of the home. Paul makes that very
clear in 1 Timothy chapter 2. Adam was
made first, not Eve. He's the head of
the home. He is the priest. So when God
told Adam in Genesis 2:16:17, "In the
day thou eatest thereof, thou shalt
surely die." Eve had not yet been made.
Adam's responsibility was to tell Eve.
Are you with me? And so a man who is not
spiritually able, I'm not saying all
spiritually weak men are useless. I'm
not saying that at all. I'm saying it
becomes a spiritual challenge.
When she has to be the spiritual head of
the church, of the home, that burden by
God's arrangement falls on you, the man.
And so I recommend when I counsel young
people, don't knowingly go into a
marriage where the man knows nothing
about Jesus.
There are no female priests in the
Bible. Not one.
He must be the spiritual head.
Amen.
Ephesians 5:25 and 26. No, 22. Let's go
to Ephesians 5:22 quickly.
It's 5:16.
We're talking about a man who's a
spiritual head. You know, Ephesians 5.
Amen. Read with me. Wives, submit
yourselves unto your husbands as unto
the Lord. For the husband is the head of
the wife, even as Christ is the head of
the church. Finish that verse. And he is
the savior of the body.
Now, Adam failed in that respect. When
Eve came to him with that fruit, he knew
what had happened. He should have said,
"My darling, I cannot join you in sin
against God. Let me talk to God for
you."
But he said, "Okie dokie." And
and he consumed the fruit, too. You see,
that was not a savior of the body. Are
you with me? We are and we don't always
do a perfect job. We are the saviors of
that body called the wife and by
extension the home. We are the saviors
and gave himself for it. The Bible says
a man who gives himself for his wife
doesn't beat her. Amen. Well, let me not
get into that. All right. The man is the
head of the home. Marry one who's
spiritually ahead of you. Amen.
Uh the next one is um
this one. Uh are you making these up,
pastor? No, I'm not. They're right here.
I'm just They're really there.
All right. Go ahead. Um,
what does God say about coffee or
caffeine intake? What does God say? Go
to 1 Corinthians chapter
chapter 3. Let's read 16-1 17. 1
Corinthians 3:16-1 17.
The word coffee is not in the Bible. The
word caffeine is not in the Bible. But
that's no problem. The word sex is not
in the Bible either. But who will deny
it? All right. 1 Corinthians 3 16:17. Do
you have that? Someone read forward.
What does that say? Know ye not that ye
are the temple of Yes. And that what the
spirit of God dwelleth in you. Keep
reading now. If any man defile the
temple of God. Come on. Him shall God
destroy. For the temple of God is holy,
which temple ye are. Now there's some
foods that defile the temple
some things and caffeine is one
stimulant.
Just go online and see is caffeine good
for you and you see all the reports.
Caffeine is not good for you. You see
there's a principle we take for granted.
Your body belongs to God.
This is literal.
Your body belongs to God. Amen.
So we have to treat it carefully. If you
loan me your car, I'm more careful with
your car than with mine.
Your body belong, your brain belongs to
God. What are you putting in it? Your
eyes belong to God. When you go to the
internet, what are you looking at?
Amen. God can take away your sight.
Say, "Okay, you don't want to stop, I'll
stop you.
This belongs to God." What are you
listening to?
This belongs to God. Are all your words
always negative? What's your problem?
We cannot defile the body of God.
That's where the Holy Ghost dwells. And
when God told the Israelites in Exodus
25:8, "Let them make me a sanctuary that
I may dwell among them." The purpose of
the sanctuary was to get rid of the
contamination of sin that God might
dwell in a clean environment. He wants
this environment clean. Whether it's
coffee or caffeine or whatever that's
harmful, cigarettes and drugs, vaping,
you name it. We invent all kinds of ways
to sin.
Anything that defiles this temple
offends God. That's where the Holy Ghost
dwells.
Jesus tells us you offend him.
Next question.
The next question. You see, don't try to
see. Don't don't try. Here's what some
of us do. We say, "How much of the world
can I bring into my spiritual life
without losing out in salvation? How
much of the world can I include?"
None.
All right.
Uh, this is a good one. Um,
you shared that Gabriel is the greatest
angel in God's presence. The highest.
Yes. Yes. The highest, right? How great
is the angel Michael in comparison to
Gabriel? Michael is a name given to
Christ. Christ is not an angel. The word
archangel, the Greek word aros means
chief, head or first, or ruler. Christ
is the commander of the angels. That's
why he's the archangel, the chief, the
ruler of the angel. Jesus Christ is not
an angel.
Go to Hebrews chapter 2.
I'm glad these questions are coming. I
have Hebrews 2.
We'll read 14-16
of Hebrews 2.
Are you there? Read with me. For as much
then as the children are partakers of
flesh and blood, he also himself
likewise took part of the same. He mean
he became human, that through death he
might destroy him that had the power of
death, that is the devil, and deliver
them who through fear of death were all
their lifetimes subject to bondage. 16
For verily he took not on him the what?
Nagege angels, but he took on him the
seed of Abraham. He did not he never
became an angel. He became human. Jesus
Christ is not an angel. He is divine and
human. The term Michael the Archangel is
Michael the head of the chief of
the commander and chief of the angels.
What is an archbishop?
He's the chief of the people under him.
What is an archeneemy? Your greatest
enemy. He is the archangel. He is the
chief of the angels, the ruler of the
angels, the head of the angel. He
himself is not an angel.
All right. Go on. By the way, Michael
means who is like God. That cannot be
said of any angel. Jesus is just like
the father. Michael means who is like
God.
So, none of us should have that name.
Okay. Go ahead.
Uh the next one is how do we and let me
just add this too. When you go to Daniel
chapters 10, it gives you the
description of Michael the archangel.
You compare that to Revelations chapters
1, the same description is given of the
son of man. So I just want to share that
caveat. Thank you, brother Pastor. Um,
question two, not question two, but how
do we honor the Sabbath and what do we
do and don't do? Let's go to uh Isaiah
58, 13-4.
It's a summary statement. Isaiah 58:13
and 14.
Read carefully. Some of you already know
this by heart.
Listen carefully.
Are you there? What book did I say?
Isaia. chapter. What verses? Read for me
now. You never read. I ask, but you
never do. Come on. If thou turn away thy
foot from the Sabbath, from doing thy
pleasure on my holy days. Stop. Notice
again. If thou turn away thy foot from
the What does that mean? Go to Genesis
13.
See if we can get some insight.
Genesis 13. Let's get some insight.
Let's read verse 15. What does God say
to Abraham?
No, no, no. Uh, all that thee will I
give into thy seed forever. Verse 16.
Mhm. Read 17.
Ah, that's it. Arise. Walk through the
land of it in the length of it. In the
Now, when you're walking, what do you
do?
You're putting your feet. Come on.
Where? On the ground. Mhm. God tells
Abraham, "Act as if it's
Yes. Act as if it's yours because I've
promised to you. You must accept it by
faith." He said, "Arise. Walk through
the length of it. From the breath of it,
I'll give it to you. Behave as if it's
yours. Now go to Job chapter 1.
Job 1. Let's read from verse 6. The book
of Job is the oldest book written in the
Bible. By the way, we believe Moses
wrote it. Oldest in the sense that it
records the oldest events before, I mean
after creation.
You have Job 1. Let's read from verse
six. Now there was a day when the sons
of God came to present themselves before
the Lord and Satan came also among them.
The sons of God from other worlds. Satan
comes representing the earth. And the
Lord said unto Satan, "Whence comest
thou?" Then Satan answered the Lord and
said, "What?"
Come on, read clearly from going to and
fro in the earth, and from walking up
and down in it. What did God tell
Abraham? Walk up and down as if it's
yours.
Satan said, "I'm just walking up in my
territory,
and I've come to represent my
territory." Now, go to Isaiah 58. Let's
read verse 13.
You have it.
Read for me. What does that say? If thou
turn away thy foot from the Sabbath, in
other words, you turn away your foot,
you stop doing what?
Acting as if
it's yours. Mhm. It's not yours.
The Bible calls it my holy day. Well,
let's read. If thou turn away thy foot
from the Sabbath from doing thy pleasure
on my holy day, my holy day, you're
acting as if it's yours. And if it's
yours, you can do whatever you like. No,
it's mine. Keep reading.
I call the Sabbath at light, holy of the
Lord, honorable, and shall honor him not
doing thine own ways, nor find thine own
pleasures, nor speaking thine own words.
So that don't do these things. Don't
find your own pleasures, do your own
work, speak any words you like. Don't
discuss the playoffs on Sabbath.
Don't discuss business on Sabbath. It's
a holy day. We need to up our
understanding of holy.
The Sabbath is a holy day. When I was a
little boy, in preparation for the
Sabbath, my mother would cover the
television set with a with a a towel. We
would turn down all magazine so you
could not see the cover to distract your
mind. Now, you may call that legalism,
but we didn't want anything to enter the
mind that did not contribute to a
spiritual climate. So, all magazines
were turned down. You couldn't see the
cover and whatever else and television
face covered, that idiot box. So, we
covered it up.
It's a holy day. And we would check each
other not because we're Pharisees. In
other words, if my friend is discussing
football, we say, "Is that appropriate
for the Sabbath?" That was a common
expression we had. Is that appropriate
for the Sabbath? And the person say,
"Oh, no, no, no, no, no. I'll discuss it
on the other the Sunday day."
Don't do whatever you like. Don't cook.
Exodus 16 from verse 23- 26. cook your
food on Friday. That's what the Bible
tells her. I will keep it fresh on
Sabbath.
You don't believe it.
If you don't have a refrigerator, cook
your food on Friday. It will be fresh on
Sabbath because I am the Lord. I change
not.
You still don't believe me. Well, you
don't believe God.
Listen to me. The God that kept food
fresh for the Israelites. We'll keep
yours fresh. Amen. Amen. We are not to
cook on the Sabbath.
Amen. That's why God sent double the
amount of mana on the sixth day. They
would not go gather it. And they weren't
supposed to cook it.
What else can we do on the Sabbath? Go
to Luke 14.
Luke 14. And how can we keep the
Sabbath?
We read from verse one.
Luke chapter 14, reading from verse one
is 5:30 precisely.
Do you have brother Luke chapter 14
verse one? And it came to pass as he
went into the house of one of the chief
Pharisees to eat bread on the Sabbath
day that they watched him. And behold,
there was a certain man before him which
had what? the dropsy. And he answering
said unto the lawyers and Pharisees, is
it lawful to heal on the Sabbath day?
Finish the verse. And I'll keep reading.
They held their peace. In other words,
the obvious answer was yes. But they did
not want that poor man healed. But Jesus
says, "Is it lawful to heal?" The
obvious answer was yes. And he took him
and healed him and let him go. What am I
saying? Part of Sabbathkeeping is
looking after the sick. You may go to
nursing home, pray for the sick, sing
songs for them if you're allowed to do
that. That's Sabbath observance.
There are members who too ill to come to
church. Go visit them. Amen. Take the
focus off you. Sabbath is not a time to
sleep all day. It's a day of rest. It's
a day of rest from self-focused
activities,
but spiritually it should be a very busy
day spiritually. And there are many
other things you can do on the Sabbath
to honor that day.
Jesus told the Pharisees in that same
chapter, Luke 14, "Which of you shall
have an ass or an ox fallen into a pit
and will not straight away pull him out
on the Sabbath day?" You can't leave
animals suffering on Sabbath and say,
"I'm off to church. Feed your dog, give
him water, then go to church, feed your
cat, your lizard, whatever you have,
take care of the animal because God made
them." Amen. H acts of mercy are
appropriate for the Sabbath. Amen. But
as you study God's word, the Holy Spirit
will tell you. But don't go swimming and
tell me you're in nature on the Sabbath.
Mm-
go swim on Monday. Are you with me and
Sunday? Not on Don't go skiing and tell
me you're visiting nature. Uh-uh. Don't
get cute with God. Are you following me?
You wakeboarding and skateboarding. I'm
enjoying the fresh air. Don't do that.
Don't be slick with God. Okay.
Uh and also I would like to read uh
Isaiah 58 which um also adds to what you
just said uh pastor that I'm going to
read some just few translations. One is
the NLT. I love the King James but the
NLT says this Isaiah 58 uh that's uh
reading from verse 13. It says this keep
the Sabbath day holy. Don't pursue your
own interests on that day, but enjoy the
Sabbath and speak of it with delight as
the Lord's holy day. Okay. The NIV says,
"If you keep your feet from breaking the
Sabbath, from doing as you please on my
holy day, and if you call the Sabbath a
delight and the Lord's holy day
honorable." So, it goes back to what the
pastor said, don't pursue your own
interest. So, um here's another one.
Hold on.
I think it goes back to what you said
similar and that is
my wife set up a group of men.
I'm still going to ask it. Go ahead. My
wife set up a group of men to kill me,
but God has delivered me from it. Mhm.
Should I stay in the marriage still? Ah,
serious business. Yes. Now, the Bible
says the major reason for divorce is
adultery. It does not forbid separation.
If ne, it does not forbid. You see,
marriage is serious is a serious thing.
You see, you can't jump in and out like
a you skipping a rope. Are you with me?
You're in, you're in. That's the
biblical version of marriage. You're in.
I almost said you're stuck, but you're
in, you're in. Are you with me? You just
can't jump out because your wife can't
cook. You're married. You're married.
Now, if something goes wrong and it's
very dangerous to your health, you may
consider separation for a while as you
get counseling. But if someone hired
someone to kill you, a unless God speaks
to you face to face and tells you stay,
there are no circumstances under which I
would tell you stay. You can separate,
but the basis for divorce biblically and
according to Ellen White is adultery,
but don't stay where your life is
actively threatened.
Or the wife hired some men to kill her
husband or the husband hired men to kill
his wife. Whatever it may be, leave that
environment. If it improves, then you'll
come back because people can change.
That's God's specialtity. people can
change.
Amen.
The next one is
I've heard some Adventists say that
Zechariah 14 is not accomplished yet.
This what does that say? Zechariah 14.
The whole chapter. Chapter 14. That's
referring to Jesus touching his foot on
the Mount of Olives. Oh. Oh. Oh. You
know that's No, it's not in the No, no.
That will be when he comes back. Mhm.
The third time. Not the second time. The
third time. And the city comes down and
lands there and becomes a flat plane.
Yes. The third time.
Yeah. I think this is a Let me say a
little more question please. When Christ
comes a second time, he does not touch
the earth. The wicked are destroyed by
his brightness. He raises the righteous
dead. They join the living righteous. We
all go to heaven. We stay a thousand
years with him judging the wicked.
Wicked people, wicked angels. After
thousand years we all come back. The
city comes with us. The city descends
the area he mount Olivet. It becomes a
plane and the city rests there. So that
when the fires come to destroy the
wicked, the fires burn all around the
city and those of us inside will see. It
won't be a pretty sight but we'll see.
That's when that prophecy will come to
pass. Okay, next question. The next one
is, what is your advice for young people
in courtship?
First, read messages to young people.
Read letters to young lovers, please.
And court someone of the similar faith.
If you're Baptist, court a Baptist.
If you're Jehovah's Witness, court a
Jehovah's Witness. As I like to say, if
you're a Satanist, court a demon. court
someone of your own faith. Are you
following me? If an SDA finish my words,
quot SDA.
You save yourself a pel of problems.
Use the word pleel up north. No, that's
a southern word. You You save yourself a
bunch of problems. Are you following me?
Be not an equally yolked together with
And an unbeliever is not someone who
doesn't go to church. An unbeliever is
someone who doesn't believe what you
believe.
Of the top five reasons for divorces,
one is communication, one is money, one
is religious differences. Of the top
five, religion is in there.
Yes, pastor. Go ahead. Uh the next one
is
by the way, let me say something. Don't
get into an unequal relationship and
then try to be a soul winner. That's not
biblical. I will win him to Christ. I
will win her. Mm- mm-
g Israelites, they will take you from
me.
They will take you from me. That's what
he told them. Go ahead. Yeah.
I think this question, let me also say
sorry. Sorry.
On occasions it has worked out on
occasion,
but when you start wrong,
you you put yourself as a disadvantage.
Are you following me? Okay. Always do
things God's way, please.
No more interruptions. Go ahead, pastor.
Um the next one is uh I think you
answered it. Okay. But it's still in the
context of marriage. Um I hope this
person is sincere but it says not to
question you know their heart. However I
I think this question requires
read it read it. Read it. Read it. It
says according to the Bible is it
allowed and I'm going to reward it. is
allowed to be intimate on the Sabbath
even if you're married. Okay, I've got
it. I've got it. Father in heaven, as I
continue, speak through us very clearly.
In Jesus name I pray. Amen. Amen. How
many days are in the week?
How many are holy? One.
You have six days
to replenish the earth. Are you
following me? Why are you bothering the
Sabbath?
I get this all the time. I don't know
why.
Who engages in that activity first with
prayer and then a Bible reading closing
him? Who? Nobody. The last thing on your
mind is God.
Go to Exodus 19. Let me show you
something.
Ah,
I thought you were nice people.
Go to Exodus 19. Let me show you
something.
I tell you, oh father,
I'm so glad God is patient. All right.
Do you have Exodus 19? God gives Moses
instructions for the Israelites. Here's
how they are to prepare. Or are you with
me? They to put a boundary around the
mountain. Anyone who touches it is dead.
Now, read what Moses tells them in verse
15 of Exodus 19. Read nice and clear.
And he said unto whom? The people. Be
ready against the come not at your
wives.
Suspend physical relations as a
spiritual preparation for the arrival of
God. Amen. Do not engage in that
activity.
If a couple had done it, finish my
words.
Mhm.
Moses said,
"Pause on that for a while." As
spiritual preparation, God is coming on
the mountain. No,
God is coming. Are you with me? So,
there's some Bible precedent for avoid
that on the Sabbath.
Not every act that God gives us is holy.
People say, "Well, it's unholy act." Who
said that? God gave Adam work, but it's
not to be done on the Sabbath. Are you
with me? Is work good? Come on. Is work
good? Yes. Is it good for the Sabbath?
No. The fact that God gave it you does
not make it suitable for the Sabbath.
Amen. Amen. Okay.
Yes, pastor. Go ahead.
Uh, the next one is, "How many do you
have left?
I'm serious.
I didn't have lunch." Okay, go ahead. Go
ahead. Go ahead.
Uh, the next one is um that some All
right. You said that some marriages God
does not sanction. Mhm. If God does not
sanction these marriages, should one
stay in these marriages or these types
of marriages? Now, that's a very good
question. If God does not sanction that
marriage, now what am I talking about?
Uh, a believer
said, um, I have heard that you're
intending a marry a man who's not of the
faith. You can neither claim nor expect
God's blessing on such a union. You
cannot exclaim acclaim nor expect God's
blessing on such a union. Now when you
say if two people marry and it was not
according to God's will, are you saying
that one is a believer, one isn't?
I'm not sure the background of the
question. The the question just said
that you said that some marriages God
did not sanction and if if God did not
sanction these marriages, should one
stay in these marriages? As in the case
earlier, I would refer that person to
the higher authorities of the church to
get clarification. Yes. Okay. Very
sensitive issue. But there are some God
does not recognize. There's some
divorces God does not recognize.
Okay. Good. The next one which I love is
this. Uh what are the three keys
things that empower you the most to obey
God's word?
Understand the love God has for you.
That is foundational. And to understand
that to some degree, you go to Calvary.
The sacrifice of Christ. That man
suffering, bleeding, dying, being
buried, spat upon, beaten, abused,
everything. Why? For you. That's where
you start. And then you see God's
working in the lives of his people. The
way he blessed Abraham, the way he
blessed whomever. God's miraculous
working in the lives of his obedient
people. You look at that and you realize
again the love of God. Those are the two
I would recommend. Study Christ, his
sacrifice. Look at how he moves among
his people, the Israelites, certain
individuals, and see his love for them,
his faithfulness to them. And then of
course look at your own life and see how
God has been merciful to you. That's why
you're still alive. how many chances God
has given you. Surely if that can't move
you to be faithful to God, I do not know
what will. But the first clearly is
Christ and his sacrifice
that will soften the heart.
Go on.
The next one is, can you
explain 1 Corinthians 14:34-35,
which it says, "Let your women keep
silence in the churches, for it is not
permitted for them to speak, but they
are commanded to be under obedience, as
also says the law." And if they will
learn anything, let them ask their
husbands at home, for it is a shame for
women to speak in the church. That's a
Bible passage that I have never seen a
satisfactory explanation for. There's
some tr not troublesome, there's some
difficult Bible passages that have not
been clearly explained. They're quite
disputed. That's one of them. So, the
church has no position on that. But I
can tell you that Ellen White spoke in
all kinds of churches and pulpits when
she was alive in this church. God had
women who spoke to the nation, who spoke
to kings. Deborah was a judge. She
addressed the nations. When the
Israelites had to go fight the
Canaanites, the Israelite king came to
Deborah and said, "I will go and fight
if you go with me." Then we have the
four daughters of Philip who were
prophetices. We have Aquill and
Priscilla. Priscilla took uh what's
that? Apollos and taught him the word
more perfectly. So there are women
clearly who were spiritual leaders in uh
Philippians 4 2 and 3. I beseech you and
I beseech Cinti to be of the same mind
in the Lord and I entreat thee also true
fellow help those women which labored
with me in the gospel and whose names
are written in the book of life. So
there were two leading women who worked
with Paul. The evidence is there were
women who delivered the word of God.
I never tell people a woman should not
because I've not clearly understood that
passage. I haven't.
I'm grateful for those women who have
spoken, particularly Sister White.
All right, my brother. Amen, pastor.
Yeah,
don't use it to go stifle women. Amen.
Please don't do that. Amen. It's an
unclear passage, not yet fully
understood. Yeah. Like praying for the
dead. Another troublesome passage in
Corinthians, not fully understood.
Yeah. Yeah. And I just want to add to
what Pastor Ski says, that's one of
those controversial uh passages. The
closest that many theologians have said
was while the preacher was preaching,
the wives would yell across the room to
ask the husband what did he say? So that
was the context of because they sat in
separate sections, right? because yeah
but um that's the closest many Christian
theologians across denominations have
come to the conclusion um the next one
is this
where in the Bible does it say we should
not wear jewelry
a couple of places let's go to uh
let's go to Exodus 35
I think that's the passage message.
Exodus 35.
You have that
pastor read for us from verse one of
Exodus 3. Not Exodus, sorry, my mistake.
Genesis 35.
Now, before the pastor reads, let me set
up what happened in Genesis 34.
In Genesis 34, Simeon and Levi, two sons
of Jacob, murdered all the men in a city
because the prince of that city had
raped their sister Dina. Jacob had 12
boys and one girl. She was raped. And so
they went to the prince and said to him
in chapter 34, "Listen, you raped our
sister. You defile her. You ought to
marry her. Do you want to marry?" He
said, "Yes, I'll marry her." Because he
was really attracted to her. They said,
"Well, you can't. We can't have her
marry an uncircumcised person like you.
You have to be circumcised. The prince
said, "Sure, I will be circumcised on
all the men in my city." Fine. So soon
thereafter they came, Levi and whomever
and circumcised all the men. Well, after
two days or three, the men couldn't
move.
Simeon and Levi came with their servants
and their swords when the men could not
fight and killed all of them,
murdered an entire city,
enslaved the women and children, took
all the possessions in the city, all the
cattle outside of the city. When the
surrounding nations heard they wanted to
destroy Jacob, so Jacob was terrified,
God intervenes. Now verse one of chapter
35. And God and God said unto Jacob
Jacob, "Arise and go up to Bethl and
dwell there." Yes. In other words, leave
the area. That's how God is solving it.
Leave the area and make there an altar
unto God that appeared unto thee when
thou fled from the face of Esau thy
brother. So God told Jacob, "Leave the
area. Go to Bethl. Build a new altar
because I want you to engage in some
spiritual work." Keep reading. Then
Jacob said unto his household, "Now
listen to what Jacob tells his
household." Mhm. to all that were with
him. Put away the strange gods that are
among you. That's one. And be clean. Be
clean and change. Change your garments.
Yeah. Put away the strange gods. Be
clean. Change your garments. That's what
he told them. Let's skip verse three.
Let's go to verse four. And they gave
And they gave unto Jacob. Jacob all
strange gods that were in their handh
and all their earrings which were in
their ears. And Jacob hid them. Now wait
a minute. What did Jacob say? Three
things should be done in verse two.
Put away the strange God. Put away the
strange God. Be clean. Be clean. And
change your garments. Change your
garments. Part of being clean then was
doing what? Taking off that stuff in
verse four. Now, here's how verse four
ends. And Jacob took them and did what?
And he hid them under the oak which was
by Sheckchum. What did Jacob do with all
the jewelry? He buried it. But what does
burying something mean?
Go to Matthew 25.
Matthew 25.
I know this is a touchy subject, but uh
all right. You have Matthew 25. Remember
the parable of the
the the p the talents. Yes. Pastor, read
from verse 14. For the kingdom of heaven
is as a man traveling into a far country
who called his own servants and
delivered unto them his goods. Now we
know the story, but let's listen to one
he gave five talents to another two and
to another one. Yeah. So, one had five,
one had two, had one, and strictly and
straightway took his
uh wait.
And to every man according to his
several abilities, and straightway took
his journey. Yes. He gave them five to
one, and he left. Now, keep reading.
Then he said that had then he that had
received the five talents went and
traded with the same and made them other
five talents. What do you understand by
traded with the same?
How did he get five more talents?
What did he do with a five?
The word starts with a U
then an S.
He used them
and produced
five more. He made use of them. Keep
reading. Mhm. And Okay. And likewise he
that had received the two, he also
gained other two. Right. So he uses two.
Keep reading. But he that had received
one went and dig in the earth and hid
his lord's money. Wait a minute. Isn't
that what Jacob did? Yeah. To the
jewelry.
What did it mean in Matthew 25 when he
hid it? Did he double the one to two?
No. Did the guy with five double it to
10? No. Did the guy with five double it
to 10? Yes. Because he used it. Did a
fellow with two double it to four?
Because he used it. Did the fellow with
one double it to two? know why he didn't
use it. How do we know that? He buried
it. Now, what did Jacob do to the
jewelry? He buried it. What's the What's
the message for us? Don't use it.
After a tremendous violation of
spiritual principles, God wants to
purify his people. He tells them, "Go to
this place. Here's what you do." Let's
look at another terrible spiritual
crisis. What does God tell them again?
Go to Genesis, not Genesis, Exodus. Now
we'll be reading verse chapter 33. Let
me set it up. The previous chapter as in
Genesis 35 and 34 in in Exodus 32 the
Israelites worshiped what?
And God was angry. God told Moses as if
to say, "Let me go, Moses. Let me kill
them and I'll start with you." Moses
said, "No, no, no, no. If you kill them,
you got to kill me." He was acting like
Christ. God was probably just testing
him. Now let's go to verse one of
chapter 33. Here is what God tells these
idolatrous Israelites.
Chapter 33:1. And the Lord said unto
Moses, "Depart, and go up hence, thou
and the people which thou hast bought up
out of the land of Egypt." What did God
tell Jacob?
Depart and go up to Bethl. Leave the
area of the spiritual crime. He's
telling the Israelites the same thing.
Depart and go from this area. Go on. and
unto the land which I swore unto
Abraham, to Isaac, and to Jacob, saying,
Unto thy seed will I give it. Yes.
And I will send an angel before thee,
and I will drive out the Canaanites, the
Amorites, the Hittites, the Pezerites,
the Hivites, and the Jebusites. Skip to
verse three. Unto the land flowing with
milk and honey, for I will not go up
into the midst of thee, for thou art a
stiff people, lest I consume consume
thee in a moment. God says, I'm not
going with you. There's some things you
ought to do. Read verse four. And when
the people heard these evil things, what
are the evil things they heard? They m
they Now, what are the evil things they
heard? I'm talking about what God was
going to do. Yes. The word evil doesn't
mean sinful. It means unfortunate. It
means calamities. When they heard what
God is about to do to them, what did
they do? Verse four says, "And when the
people heard these evil tidings, they
mourned, and no man did put on him his
ornaments." He took off all of it. Now
read verse five and six. For the Lord
had said to Moses, "Say unto the
children of Israel, ye are stiff necked
people, and I will come up in the midst
of thee in a moment, and consume thee."
Listen carefully now. Therefore now, put
off thy ornaments from thee. Yes. That I
may not that I may know what to do unto
thee. Yes. He said, "Take it off." Read
six. And the children of Israel stripped
themselves of their ornaments. What does
strip mean? Take it off everything. And
Bible scholars tell us there's no
evidence in scripture to ever put it
back on again. Let's leave the Old
Testament. Go to 1 Timothy chapter 3,
chapter 2. 1 Timothy, chapter 2. Let's
read from verse 9.
1 Timothy chapter 2. Reading from verse
9.
Do we have that? Amen. Read for us,
pastor. Uh, 1 Timothy chapter 2, reading
from verse 9. In like manner also that
women adorn themselves themselves in
modest apparel with shame face and
not with boarded hair or pearls or
costly array. So we have that verse
saying that's not the way a woman should
adorn herself. Keep reading. But which
becometh women professing God with good
works. Yes. Let the women learn. No,
that's fine. That's fine. So Paul says
you don't need all that stuff to adorn
yourself. Go to first Peter chapter 3.
Now let's read from verse one.
First Peter chapter 3 reading from verse
one.
Peter chapter 3 verse one. Likewise
letwise wives be in subjection to your
own husbands. that any obey not the
word, they also may without the word be
one by the word. In other words, let
your lifestyle win your unbelieving
husband. Go on. While they behold your
chase conversation, your upright life
coupled with fear respect for him. Keep
reading. Whose adorning let it not be
the outward adorning of plating of the
hair of or the wearing of gold. Yes. So
we have this gold here again. Peter said
that's not the way to adorn yourself.
Verse four, but let it be the hidden man
of the heart. Yes. Adorn this that which
is not corruptible, even a meek and
quiet ornament of a meek and quiet
spirit. Finish. Which in the sight of
God of a great Ah, Peter says, adorn
this,
not this. Now go to Revelation 12.
This one is a little tricky. Revelation
12. We look at two women in Revelation
12. Two women Mhm. One represents God,
one represents false teachers or false
churches. Revelation 12, let's read from
verse one. And there appeared a great
wonder in heaven, a woman clothed with
the sun and the moon under her feet, and
upon her head a crown of 12 stars. What
does a woman have? Tell me quickly.
Clothed with a sun, the moon under her
feet. Upon her head a crown of 12 stars.
That's all she has.
Put all of that together. Give me one
word. Light. Light. Light. That's her
garment. Go to Revelation 17. Let's look
at Babylon.
Revelation 17. Babylon.
Let's read verse four. And the woman was
arrayed with purple scarlet color.
Uhhuh. And decked with gold and precious
stones pearls and having golden cup in
her hand full of abominations and
filthiness of fornication. Now look at
the way the two women are addressed.
Which one represents God's true church?
The one in Revelation 12. Which one is
Babylon? 117. Then you have to ask
yourself, who do I want to look like?
That goes for men and women.
Are you with me? That goes for men and
women.
Not just women, men and women. In other
words, the Christian does not draw
attention to the outside unnecessarily.
The Bible says adorn this. Let me show
you one other thing. Go to Genesis
chapter 3 quickly. Genesis 3
as quickly as you can at 6:00 on the
dot.
We started at 4. It's now 6.
Supper time. Okay. Do we have Genesis
chapter? What did I say? Genesis chapter
3. Let's read from verse
seven.
And the eyes of them were both open and
they knew that they were naked. Naked.
And they and they sewed fig leaves to
together and made themselves aprons.
Where do you put aprons? Around your
liver, your heart. Where do you put
aprons? The outside.
Aprons are the first thing the Bible
records that human beings ever made. It
was something to make the outside look
better.
Are you with me? It was an attempt to
fix an internal problem.
But you and I cannot fix the internal.
God fixes that. So they did what they
could or thought they could. They made
something on the outside. The very first
thing humanity ever made was something
to decorate the out and God took it off.
Replaced it with quotes of skin
representing the righteousness of
Christ.
Mhm. So the Adventist church does not
recommend it. We urge you not to do it.
But we know God will talk to you and you
will take that action as he moves you.
Let me show you something. Go to
Galatians 1. When I tell you God will
move you. Go to Galatians 1.
Let's read from verse 13. We'll read 13-
15 of Galatians 1. See how God moves
when he's ready.
And we should not sometimes run ahead of
God. Do you have Galatians 1? Let's read
from 13. What does that say? For you've
heard of my convers. Let the pastor get
it. Pastor, do you have it? Galatians
chapter 1. One from verse 13. Verse 13.
For you've heard of my conversation.
Yes. For he have heard of my
conversation in time past in the Jewish
religion. How that beyond measure I
persecuted the church of God and wasted
it. Now what was Paul doing? Killing
people. Are you with me? Killing people
not physically but just as guilty in
God's eyes. Keep reading. And profited
in the Jews religion above many my
equals in my own nation being more
zealous. Yes.
jealous zealous of the traditions of my
father. Now read 15 carefully. But when
it pleased God. Ah stop.
Do you think the Jews wanted Paul to
stop killing them immediately?
Mhm. Paul said when it pleased God.
The Holy Spirit will do a work on
someone. when it pleased God who
separated me from my mother's womb and
called me by his grace to reveal his son
in me. When it pleased God,
there's some things only God can change
and we cannot. Are you with me? All
right, next question, pastor.
Uh
the next one um is this. How many more
are left?
You know what? I think I'm gonna end in
15 minutes. Is that okay? Okay, go
ahead.
Where are these questions coming from?
Go ahead. Go ahead. Go ahead. All right.
There's something called temperance. All
right. Go ahead, pastor. Go ahead. Let
me get to this last one and then I'm
going to grab one in the audience. Okay.
I am listening. Um, what is your
understanding on Constantine changing
all the Bible's original names in the
Bible and why? Yeah. So, that's the
first question. Mhm. Constantine
changing all the original names. What
does that mean? Basically what it's uh
it is believed that when the early
church came together after the
conversion supposedly of Constantine he
wanted all the writings of the prophets
and patriarchs put together and he
wanted to assemble which book should be
together and used for uh the state of
Christianity. So in other words, the
question is asked, what is your
understanding of Constantine changing
all the Bible's original names? Names as
far as for example, why do we use the
word God, Lord, and Jesus instead of
Yahwh, Yahushua? And are we taking his
name in vain?
Oh, okay.
Yeshua.
in the 19
I don't know what Constantine did but
there was in the 1920s I think or 30s
there was a movement began called the
holy name movement. Yeah.
And the the the person who popularized
this said that we ought to say
uh Yeshua and we ought to say Abba. We
ought to use these names.
It never went very far but it affected
some people. There's some people today
who still think you ought to say Yeshua.
You ought to say uh Yahweh or whatever
instead of God and uh Jesus.
Go to Acts chapter 9. Let me show you
something. Acts 9.
Because if that's the case, all the
Bible writers in the New Testament are
wrong. Are you with me? Because they
never use those terms if you read the
New Testament carefully. Go to Acts 9.
Let's read from verse read from verse
three. This is Paul going to rest more
people.
You have Acts chapter 9. Read from verse
three. And as they journeyed, he came
near. Suddenly there shined around about
him a light from heaven fell and he fell
to the earth and heard a voice saying to
him, "Saul, Saul, why persecutest thou
me?" Now listen carefully. And he said,
"At thou, Lord? Who are you?" What does
the what does the person say? And he
said, and he says, "I am Jesus." That's
what he said. Okay, that's fine. I am
Jesus.
Now, red letters give us the exact words
of Jesus. That's why they're in red. I
am Jesus.
When God sent the angel Gabriel to
Joseph, call his name Jesus.
All through from Matthew to Revelation
is Jesus Christ,
Messiah, Savior, Lord. And as
Adventists,
all through the writings of Ellen White,
it's the same thing. She never ever
complained about the name Jesus or said
we shouldn't do it. The holy name
movement, which began, I think, the 20s
or 30s of the past century, popularized
this belief. You ought to say Yeshua and
you ought to say that. But to now the
Jews did not like to use the absolutely
holy name of God which is Yahweh.
You know it's called the
tetetrogrammaton. You have these four uh
consonants and then you fit in uh um
vowels vowels to produce a pronunciation
but there were no vowels. And so the
Jews chose not to use that and they
replace it with Adoni which means Lord
in the in the New Testament. But we do
not recognize
Jesus as a sinful reference to the
savior. No.
The Christian churches, whether
Adventists or not, Jesus is a proper
title. Lord is a proper title. God is a
proper title.
Next question. Amen.
And uh but if someone wants to if
someone wants to say Yeshua, don't call
the police. Don't jump on the purge.
want to do that, go ahead. But don't try
to force it onto me.
Go on. Amen. Amen. Um Jude had a
question.
I just want to first of all thank our
pastor for getting you here. Okay. I
don't know how that all happened because
I know you go all over the world. Right.
Right. I want to ask you if you will
please please come and visit us again.
But the Lord willing, yes, my lovely
sister. The Lord will have enjoyed
myself spiritually, socially, on every
level. I leave without one complaint.
You taught me very very much. Well, God
bless you and praise God. Praise God.
Praise God. Mhm. Praise God.
Oh, hold on.
If we are supposed to pray to the father
in the name of Jesus, what happened when
we say Jesus help me or Okay, good
question.
Jesus tells us, let's look at his
example.
John 17. Let's go to John 17.
Let's read from verse
two.
We'll read from verse one. These words
spake Jesus. Well, let's pray again.
Father, continue to speak through me and
the pastor. I pray please in Jesus name.
Amen. These words spake Jesus and lifted
up his eyes to heaven and said what?
Father the hour has come. Glorify thy
son that thy son also may glorify thee.
Go to verse five.
What does that say? And now, oh father.
And now, oh father. So he calls him
father. Six times in that prayer he
refers to him as father. Look at verse
24.
Father, I will that they also whom thou
has given me be with me where I am. Look
at verse 25.
Oh righteous father. Six times I believe
he prays to the father. The father, the
father. Now in Matthew 6, go to verse 9.
Matthew 6:9.
After this manner therefore pray ye
what? Our father. So Jesus tells us pray
to the father. Now that does not mean if
the moment of Christ you say Jesus help
me that all of heaven go silent. God
reads this. You see God reads this. So
now God won't go silent. But Jesus tells
us the proper way to pray is pray to the
father in my name. The father will do it
because of me. I am the intercessor. and
the one who died based on my sacrifice
he will answer you and bless you and so
the proper way is to the father through
Jesus Christ under the guidance of the
holy spirit that's the proper way I've
heard so many people pray to the father
then they say in your name I praym you
pray in the name you must be conscious
of what you're saying you father in the
name of Jesus thank you because you
recognize his sacrifice is the reason
why the father can answer you. You don't
pray to the father in the father's name.
I've heard ministers pray that way. You
pray father this whatever bless my
enemies whatever forgive my sins in the
name of Jesus which is equivalent to
saying on the basis of that sacrifice
take away that sacrifice God will not
even hear you far less answer you even
though he loves you there's a scientific
you know Ellen White talks about the
science of prayer the there's a way to
do things God understands in the moment
of the crisis but it's good to know
there is a way to the father in the name
of Jesus under the leading of the Holy
Spirit.
Okay? But they don't we'll get to my
lovely sister. If you ask 10 little
children to pray, they all pray to Jesus
because they're taught that way. But
children ought to be taught no pray to
God the Father in the name of Jesus.
Now, when they pray, God hears them.
Don't misunderstand me. But the same way
they can pray to Jesus, they can
understand. Pray to the father in the
name of Jesus Christ. So you recognize
Christ. Take Christ out of the picture.
The father can do nothing for you no
matter how much he loves you. Yes, my
dear sister.
So, in one of your sermons earlier, I
think last week, uh, you had mentioned
that you when you get to the kingdom
that one of the first people you want to
see, I thought you said was Eleazar.
Yes. And I think you said you were going
to explain what Oh, did I? And so, I
wanted to hear why. Okay. The reason
why.
Let's go to Genesis 15. Let me tell you
why. I love Eleaza. Nobody loves Eleazar
except me. I love Eleaza. Let me tell
you why. Whenever I say that's my
favorite character, people look at me as
though I am strange, which I am, but not
for that reason. Do you have Genesis 15?
Read from verse one.
Pastor, you have it. Yes. Read for us.
After these things, the word of the Lord
came unto Abram in a vision, saying,
Fear not, Abram. I am thy shield and thy
exceeding great reward. Okay, by the
way, earlier in this morning's message,
we said Jesus is our our peace, our he's
also our shield and our reward because
the person talking to Abraham is Jesus
Christ in in Genesis 15 also the Old
Testament the father sees all the
reccomunication after sin. Okay, I am
thy shield, thy seed and great reward.
Verse two, and Abraham said, Lord God,
what will thou give me seeing I go
childless? childless, I have no heir.
And the steward in my house is this
Eleazarus.
The plan was if Abraham had no child,
Eleazar would inherit everything.
Eleazar knew that.
Yet when Abraham wanted a wife for
Isaac,
Abraham choose the guy who could have
had everything Isaac would get and sent
him because Abraham trusted him. Meaning
and Eleazar prayed for the right woman
for Isaac. He went when he found her,
let's say he found a Tuesday, he left
Wednesday morning, headed straight back
to Abraham to report the success of the
mission. He did not have one envious
bone in his body.
He called Abraham his master. He called
Isaac his master.
Even though he knew if Abraham never had
a son, he would have everything.
I like that
he prayed. You want to learn about this
man? Read Genesis 24. Almost the whole
chapters about him. Read Genesis 24
60some verses, I think. Eleazar,
the chief servant of Abraham, who
symbolizes the Holy Ghost as Abraham is
God, Isaac, Jesus, and Rebecca the
church. That's why I want to see Eleazar
first.
A praying man, unselfish.
All right. Next, uh
All right.
617.
What is the correct way for a Christian
to deal with chronic pain without taking
drugs? Chronic pain without taking
drugs. Now, our health principles do not
promote the use of drugs. But we do
believe in some acute cases a drug may
be necessary to stabilize a person or
even save a life. But we don't promote
drugs as a normal way of dealing with
problems. We would suggest you, I would
suggest you that you consult with some
sort of natural health care professional
who can provide you with options other
than drugs because drugs can have some
serious side effects. And of course, as
a child of God, you have God on your
side. He's promised there shall be no
more pain, but that can begin now to a
certain degree. So if you're dealing
with pain, I recommend seeing a health
care professional who is a natural
health care professional. Get some
recommendations
and see if that helps along with asking
for divine help.
But do all you can to avoid using drugs.
The side effects are horrific. Again,
let me say there may be acute conditions
where a drug is necessary to stabilize
the person or save a life. But as a
matter of health practice, we avoid
drugs.
All right, somebody else. All right,
we'll take uh two more and then we will
close. Okay, uh Anthony and then Noel.
Um, and over the past oh I don't know a
couple years I've listened to your
sermons and you mentioned inside of the
ark of the covenant is the ten
commandments which the cherub on the
sides they're looking down because they
are just in awe of the fact that there's
of the mercy that's in the ten
commandments. There's also the bowl of
mana and the
we we don't talk about that very much in
our church but it has I mean I I'm
giving the ten commandments utmost
respect. But there's also mana and
Aaron's rod that budded in there. Should
we be also paying attention to them?
Originally, it was only the ten
commandments because they were placed in
there before Aaron's priesthood was
challenged. And then God told them,
"Bring a rod." And that's long before
that happened. Only the ten commandments
were in there. But after the challenge
and the the the the the twigs became
rods uh ammon they bore ammons and then
the manner then God included uh a
certain amount of mana plus Aaron's rod
within the ark itself yes but of the
three the law because there'll come a
time when we don't need that rod no more
priest we don't need mana but the ten
commandments will always remain the
commandments are the foundation of God's
universal kingdom justice Yes.
Okay. Uh thank you pastor. Yes my
brother. With regards to reverence, can
we clap our hands in church? With regard
to reverence. Yes. Can we clap our hands
in church? Clapping is mentioned in the
Bible. But there is a department of the
general conference called the biblical
research institute. Their function is to
study the Bible, provide answers for the
church leaders before they make
important decisions. And several years
ago, I read a uh a study one of them did
a brief study that showed that clapping
was not used in the worship service in
the Old Testament.
Okay. Thank you. You're welcome. I
wanted to ask uh can we drink uh can we
eat? Can we chew in church as well?
Well, church is not a restaurant.
You see, can you do that in a courtroom?
No, you can. No. Don't do it before God,
the judge of all the universe. Mhm.
Thank you. Right.
So, I'm going to end this with a uh note
here uh that says uh from the bottom of
our hearts, Pastor Ski, we bless the
Lord for blessing us with you in this
season to encourage us to challenge us
to obey the father without excuse or
conditions before him. And the promise
here is given in Psalms 92:12-15,
which states, "The righteous shall
flourish like the palm tree. He shall
grow like a cedar in Lebanon. And those
that be planted in the house of the Lord
shall flourish in the courts of our God.
They shall still bring forth fruit in
old age, and they shall be fat and
flourishing to show that the Lord is
upright. He is my rock, and there is no
unrighteousness
in him.
And that is
just just words of encouragement. Okay.
Well, thank you very much. Let me say
very quickly, I'm very grateful to God
for the honor he gave me to fellowship
with you. I say that knowing he's
listening to me. I was greatly honored
to speak for him. I'll try to do a
better job next time. It was a pleasure,
a spiritual, social, physical pleasure
to fellowship with you. God bless you in
every possible way. Save you. And may he
use you as saviors to others. You see
what I mean? So that by your lifestyle,
if nothing else, someone comes to
Christ, not goes from him, by your
behavior, your conduct, someone comes to
Christ. And this is what he desires for
us. If I be lifted up, will draw all men
unto me. And Christ wants to lift
himself up in us so others may see
Christ in us. My prayer for you is that
you will remain faithful
even unto death. Revelation 2:10. We are
moving into some serious times. I know
you've heard that before, but the
evidence is too obvious. We're moving
into some serious times. Elise said all
the provisions of the constitution will
be removed and we see the attacks on the
constitution very direct and very clear.
She also says the final movements will
be rapid ones. And so we need to walk
with God hand in hand, day by day,
moment by moment. Are you with me? so
that we can be faithful to him
regardless of the trials that come upon
us. Do everything you can to secure your
children for the kingdom. If you don't
want to go, prepare them to go. Are you
following me? Let them enter ahead of
you. If you have unconverted family
members, do what you can to attract them
to the truth of Jesus Christ without
preaching their heads off. Just show the
love of Christ and see what that does
for them. May the Lord bless you. Bless
your children. Bless your homes. Make
your homes a fortress protected by
mighty angels. When you drive, may you
be safe on the highways. May he protect
your jobs. Provide your needs. Always
put you in a position where you can
give. Why? It is more blessed to give
than to receive. If someone offends you,
forgive the person. Sometimes we say
things the wrong way at the wrong time.
Forgive. Are you following me? We're not
perfect. Forgive and forget so that the
church can run smoothly. Do what you can
to make sure your presence has an impact
on the surrounding area. And if God
wills, he'll bring me back when it
pleases him. And I'll if he says so,
I'll come with great joy. God bless you.
Thank you for treating me so well. And
if we don't see each other again, let's
meet where on the sea of glass. If any
time I pop into your mind, please say,
"Lord,
put your words in, please." God bless
you and I love you.
Yes. Um, this is our gift to you on a
behalf of the church. We want to say
thank you for ministering for the Lord
Jesus Christ.
Thank you, church. In as much as you've
done it unto one of the least, and
that's me, my brethren, you have done it
unto me, says God. So may God be
praised. Thank you. God bless you.
Pastor, you have a nice pastor.
Take care of him, protect him, thank God
for him, don't let him go.
Uh I want to say uh thank you for those
who were tuning in in our evening
program. I want to say God bless each
and every one of you and also want to
say subscribe to our channel by God's
amazing grace and I would like to close
out this segment with a word of prayer.
Father God would like to say thank you
for giving us the privilege to have a
great two week through your manservant
but truly you are the one that spoke and
no man gets any credit but Jesus Christ.
We ask that you may allow us to be
faithful to the end and help us Lord if
we have challenges. Thank you for loving
us and giving us the Holy Spirit to
enable us in Jesus name. Amen. All
right.